[Musique]
autrefois nombre d'alsaciens apprenait
le français en arrivant à l'école
aujourd'hui pour ces jeunes celle
inverse on parle le français à la maison
et alsaciens vis rondelles de l'école
jean petit à lingolsheim ici trois
niveaux de maternelle suivent une
scolarité en immersion à parts égales
entre langues régionales et allemands en
cp saison suivront les cours en allemand
puis à parts égales entre français et
allemands à partir du ce1 l'école est
porté par l'association abcm qui entend
permettre l'enseignement bilingue en
langue régionale 3 langues quelques
années rien de compliqué pour le jeune
cerveau ce qui nous demanderait un
travail acharné et pour les tout-petits
d'une facilité déconcertante
alors ils sont tout petits se sont
effectivement deux nouvelles langues
la plupart ne les ont pas entendu la
façon dont nous nous instruisons les
enfants en fait va être de façon
naturelle comme à la maison lorsqu'on
apprend le français avec tout le
quotidien en fait qu on apprend en
français avec les enfants nous ici tout
le quotidien on le fait en allemand ou
un alsacien donc les activités les
plaisirs les jeux tout se fait donc en
allemand et en alsacien
c'est justement là j'ai envie de dire
vraiment la réussite pour ces enfants là
parce que ça va être appris de façon
naturelle c'est vraiment une langue de
communication et c'est pas comme nous
quand on a appris à partir de la sixième
ou là on va être que dans la grammaire
et en orthographe
on va vraiment utiliser cette langue là
dans le quotidien
à partir des années 90 nombre
d'associations locales oeuvre à
développer l'enseignement bilingue à ce
moment-là pratique de l'alsacien est en
net repli dans les jeunes générations
transformant de fait le rhin en
frontière linguistique
aujourd'hui ce sont 25 à 30 mille élèves
en alsace qui suivent un cursus bilingue
français-allemand un enseignement qui
connaît un véritable boom depuis une
quinzaine d'années ça a été une
croissance qui s'est accélérée au cours
des dix à quinze dernières années
les débuts ont été bien sûr difficile
c'était site par site et puis maintenant
je dirais qu'il ya une certaine habitude
quand même de 1,2 d'ouvrir des classes
bilingues
aujourd'hui on se heurte plutôt à des
problématiques de recrutement
d'enseignants parce que voilà le succès
fait qu'il ya un besoin croissant et
c'est ce côté là qui lors des pauses des
difficultés depuis plusieurs décennies
les promoteurs de l'enseignement
bilingue ont pu compter sur le soutien
des départements alsace et un dans le
haut rhin
on mène depuis longtemps une politique
volontariste en la matière ainsi la
question du bilinguisme s'est retrouvé
au coeur du projet de collectivité
européenne dallas par exemple le futur
super départements alsaciens souhaite
pouvoir recruter ces enseignants qui
longtemps dans les clubs dans le cadre
de la collectivité européenne d'alsace
nous avons obtenu c'est dans la loi du 2
août 2019 que la collectivité européenne
alsace puisse recruter des intervenants
bilingue pour développer l'enseignement
de l'allemand aux côtés et en complément
de l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui s'il n'est pas encore
question de recrutement d'enseignants
le mouvement est bien en marche le
conseil départemental et l'association
els terne se sont donné rendez vous à
l'école maternelle de wolxheim pour
poser la première pierre d'un dispositif
ambitieux aujourd'hui avec l'association
alterne alsace
nous venons de signer une convention
pour une préfiguration de ce qui pourra
être fait par la collectivité européenne
d'alsace c'est à dire que nous allons
recruter dont les jours qui viennent un
intervenant bilingue qui sera aux côtés
de l'éducation nationale dans le
périscolaire dans les écoles et au
collège qui sera là pour donner envie
aux jeunes d'apprendre l'allemand
et puis surtout pour leur enseigner
l'allemand mais dans un cadre beaucoup
plus ludique qui donne envie aux jeunes
d'apprendre cette langue
l'intervenant aura pour mission de
donner envie d'apprendre la langue
allemande au 333 élèves de la communauté
de communes du pays de brisach
le conseil départemental assure le
financement du poste
l'association eltern sera quant à elle
chargée du recrutement et pilotage nous
allons recruter sept personnes nous
allons imaginer avec elle et pour elle
les initiatives qui doivent être prises
pour dynamiser
l'enseignement de la langue régionale
ici dans ce dans ce secteur et ensuite
cette personne sera chargée de mettre en
oeuvre ces initiatives qui peuvent être
soit au niveau de la petite enfance soit
au niveau des parents sont au niveau
associatif ou culturelles mettre en
oeuvre ces initiatives qu'on aurait
imaginé les tester vérifier si elle
amène des résultats positifs qui vont se
mesurer en termes tout simplement
d'inscriptions d'enfants bilingues dans
les écoles et si tout ça fonctionne bien
ce qu'on espère bien sûr créer une sorte
de concept qu'ils soient réutilisables
dans d'autres secteurs
le bilinguisme d'importants enjeux
notamment au niveau du développement
économique
c'est tout petits sont bien sûr trop
jeunes pour travailler demain en
maîtrisant la langue de goethe
ils pourront sans problème trouver un
emploi outre-rhin la maîtrise de la
langue allemande pouvant aussi être un
atout dans les entreprises du côté
français il ya des enjeux qui sont
importants les enjeux cultural de
l'alsace mais aussi des enjeux de
d'emploi puisqu'il ya des milliers
d'emplois qui sont aujourd'hui proposés
dans un cercle de 30 40 km pour des
jeunes et des moins jeunes qui serait
bilingue français allemand ou même
français alsacien en phase test en 2020
le dispositif des intervenants bilingue
devrait se renforcer l'année prochaine
avec la création officielle de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace